It's a little translation, I'm sure it's going through from the morning, I'm
still at
all
worried, isn't it
silk? That's not the case.  Here
's the Queen I chose. If you leave it alone, you'll just keep hitting the punching bag,
so I asked Miyagi-san to rent Aragaki as a maze
sparring partner.
[  Music]
I'm not strong enough, I think it's better than a punching bag.
Let's get started.
Nikkei
. Your legs are already good. Don't worry.
Don't get too hot
Don't forget about sparring 10
Hey, I'm glad I can hit each other and I can't help
pa Arakaki Moda
I got off the ring when I was convinced by myself, but I'm happy when I got in touch with you  I didn't
do it,
thank you, Say Miyagi,
this is the one to say thank you, I
can believe it because I was able to fight the champion together, but only three months ago he
was doing a punching bag with me in the underground ring.
I knew what would happen to humans tomorrow because I was fighting the champion,
so I paid that much for
it. It would be the same for the place, Aragaki
, and you.
It's not over,
that's it